The ocean represents over 70% of the planet,
and understanding how the ocean is changing
under climate change is critically important
to understanding how we are going to affect
the future of humankind and the planet itself.
The ocean's absorbed about 90 percent of the
heat that we've added to the earth from global
warming.
We really don't know what's going to happen
in the future, and that's the scariest thing.
The variability of the temperature in the
data we're collecting can tell us about how
deeper water is mixing in the surf zone.
That's really important to know if we want
to understand how climate change is going
to affect coastal communities.
Tyler Cyronak is a science advisor for the
Smartfin project, a citizen science initiative
that is working with surfers to help gather
data on one of the biggest environmental problems
that we face today - global warming.
Since the modern industrial revolution ocean
temperatures have risen by almost 1 degree
celsius.
That might not sound like a lot but that’s
led to melting arctic ice, rising sea levels,
decimated fish populations and the destruction
of coral reefs in coastal zones.
We don't really have a great understanding
of how temperatures are changing in coastal
zones because it's quite difficult to measure
via satellite.
And the data needed to help evaluate this
problem can’t be collected from shore, or
from deep ocean buoys either.
But that’s where Smartfins come in.
We don't have a tremendous amount of coastal
wave data from right where the waves are actually
breaking.
So we can start to fill that gap.
The Smartfin is equipped with sensors and
it fits onto a regular surfboard.
Right now the device measures ocean temperature,
motion, and location data; but it’s hoped
it will eventually collect pH, acidification,
salinity and water quality data as well.
Because the coastal zone is teeming with life,
this data will be vital to understanding how
rising temperatures are affecting sensitive
ocean habitats.
The really cool thing about Smartfin is that
it's a citizen science project.
It’s working with communities to get a better
understanding of ocean health.
We're not trying to create a Fitbit for the
oceans or for surfers.
We're trying to create a true research and
communication tool.
Plus, the 50 surfer scientists using the smartfin
to collect data are stoked to be helping save
the oceans they love.
And some of the data they’ve already collected
is surprising.
I don't think I was expecting to see so much
variability in the temperature of the surf
zone.
Inherently, we knew this already, being surfers.
You're out there and while you're surfing
you can feel warm and cold patches, but to
see that it's actually varying by three or
four degrees in just a very small amount of
space is pretty interesting.
What’s more, using the fin is simple.
Just replace your board’s fin, turn it on
and paddle out.
Then after your surf session, the data is
easily uploaded to the cloud.
And one thing that its makers want to be clear
about, the Smartfin will not stop you from
catching the perfect wave.
Just by being in the water all a surfer has
to do is keep the thing charged and go surf;
and they’ll going to be out in the water
anyway so why not collect a little data while
they’re at it.
But the project is so much bigger than just
catching waves and collecting data.
Surfers represent a unique angle to talk about
climate change.
We want to tap into that and come together
as a community and discuss why it’s important
for us to care about the oceans and why climate
change is a big deal.
We need to add some hope to that conversation,
and hopefully the surf
community can do that.